One of the biggest challenges
that Asian-Americans face
is that they're behind the scenes.
>> They don't wear
the passion on their sleeves.
>> We don't put ourselves out there
enough, we're just not being seen for
executive positions.
>> I don't think there is enough
Asian-American executives who are actually
asking for help.
[MUSIC]
There exists different values
between Asian family tradition and
American corporate culture system.
>> Asian American executives have had
a reputation for technical competence.
Their fundamental challenges
are a sense of invisibility,
leading teams, taking risks,
and speaking up.
>> I look at the program as
providing an opportunity for
our attendees to be even more
successful in their jobs.
>> It helped build my awareness about
the Asian tendencies that I have.
I needed to do a better job at being
more visible with my accomplishments.
>> The program opens my eyes to
this concept of managing up and
also exerting power.
>> It gave you a different frame work
about how you need to think about business
when you're at the upper tiers.
>> It's really personal insights and
awareness in terms of what it takes to
be an executive at corporate levels.
>> It's really improved my
effectiveness at the office,
improved my executive communications.
>> The faculty are world class.
They really believe in you and
they want you to succeed.
>> The ALP program moved my
career from the C level staff for
a company in one of the hottest
areas in social analytics.
>> I really believe that my recent
promotion was in part due to ALP.
It gave me the tools and
skills I needed to be successful,
not only in this position but
in my future ones.